on wednesday multiple outlets reported
that kanye west is the richest black
person in america
worth as much as 6.6 billion dollars
the news comes after bloomberg reported
that his sneaker brand easy
as well as easy gap have a combined
value of as much as 4.7 billion dollars
the article also mentions an additional
1.7 billion dollars in assets
but based on forbes estimates kanye is
worth less than a third of that
1.8 billion dollars that's a big jump
from last may when forbes pegged his net
worth at 1.3 billion dollars but nowhere
near the purported 6.6 billion
so how did forbes come to this estimate
forbes number is based on that
old-fashioned idea of current revenues
not theoretical future expectations the
bloomberg story cites a ubs report on
his businesses
the same document forbes saw earlier
this month
the bank made some assumptions based on
projected future earnings
particularly for easy gaap which is yet
to sell one item of clothing
forbes's breakdown of his assets looks
like this his yeezy sneaker brand is
worth an estimated 1.5 billion dollars
west owns 100 of the brand which had 214
million dollars in operating income in
a 9x multiple and a 20 private company
discount gets us to the 1.5 billion
mark west owns 160 million dollars in
cash and other assets consisting of
property
artwork jewelry and livestock among
other holdings
his music catalog which pays millions in
royalties each year
has a value of 90 million dollars west
cashed in another 64 million dollars
from his stake in skims his soon to be
ex-wife's shapewear and loungewear
company and while west's team
insists his deal with gap is worth 1.5
billion dollars
forbes isn't giving the line any value
until the products
start to sell forbes estimates that the
richest black person in the u.s
remains vista equities robert f smith
with an estimated six billion dollars
while aliko dangote of nigeria remains
the richest black person in the world
with an estimated 11.8 billion dollars
[Music]
you